all right so today is the end of our
three-day memorial day weekend it's a
time to celebrate and it's a time to
remember there are events across the
valley today to honor service men and
women who died serving our country
falcaholman joining us live with how
local veterans groups are remembering
their fallen comrades bianca good
morning
good morning john good morning heather
so after two years the unlv's veterans
club they hosted a 60-mile rug and so
they were volunteers and veterans that
carried backpacks from armagosa to here
in las vegas
now this weekend the unlv chapter rebel
vets held operation battle board it's a
nevada statewide memorial ruck march the
purpose is to honor the fallen veterans
and gold star families those who marched
held rucksacks with dog tags of 7
thousand service members including 59
nevadans the group worked hard as a team
worked
as a team to symbolically lay them to
rest at southern nevada veterans
memorial cemetery and besides this there
are several ways that people around the
valley can honor our veterans
memorial day is to fly your flags at
half staff if you have a flag that's on
the side of your house that you can't
lure to half staff what you can do to
represent half staff is to tie a black
ribbon around it
so if you tie a black ribbon around the
at the top of the flagstaff
that represents that it's at half mass
flyer flags for the holidays for the to
remember our veterans it's just nice to
see in the neighborhoods
so you can do that as well as attend
several of the events happening across
the valley there's a legion group that's
hosting event at the lake also unlv's
veteran chapter will be at the southern
nevada veterans memorial cemetery so
again taking a moment of silence to
remember our veterans that have fallen
during their time of service bianca
holman live local now